[Music]
what's up guys we asked for some
questions regarding the fight world and
you sent them so your boy's gonna answer
them the team here at thick boy Studios
picked out some of their favorite
questions so let's Jump Right In
the man at
ichikan89 i c h a c o n 89 what's
popping daddy uh what would be the next
Super fight you would like to see in the
UFC for example volkanovsky versus Islam
good question
um I mean I guess it's a super fight I
think it's and I when I say this this is
you know the big UFC 287 is Saturday
Pierre and Izzy's happening so I think
this happens regardless whether it's a
you considered a super fight or not but
Alex Pierre at light heavyweight against
Jamal Hill is a fight that they can take
all my money I think it's only a matter
of time no matter what happens win lose
or draw
um I think Pierre's future is that light
heavyweight he's too big for 85
especially as he's getting older and I
think his future is that light
heavyweight which I think he will have
the same success that he has that
middleweight I think there's better
matchups form at light heavyweight more
Strikers not so many have heavy
Grapplers because you only get
middleweight if you were to win on
Saturday against Izzy
the rest of that division is not a great
match-up form you know and if he's going
to stay at 85 and defend his title if he
was going to win on Saturday and defend
his title uh he's probably looking at a
hamzat fight next which is stylistically
a complete nightmare for him so
um I think that would be considered a
super fight depending how you uh
Define super
um but Alex appear up at light
heavyweight against uh the champion
Jamal Hill to me would be a pretty cool
super fight so hopefully that answered
your question ichacon what else you got
Michael
friedman1221 if Moz Vidal Jorge Mazda
wins do you see him ever rematching
Colby Covington I don't think so
my initial response is absolutely not
but they did have that weird beef right
where there's the you know you press
he's gonna press charges against him
that went away
um
man that's a good question
I don't think uh I don't think so I
don't think so my again my initial
response is absolutely not uh you hear
mods without talks you know about how
this surprise last one especially here
to lose whenever you hear a guy talking
about this my last one you know he's one
foot in one foot out and I know for a
fact Mazda doll has a lot going on
outside the Octagon so I I just don't
see him fighting a guy in Kobe counting
Covington has a lot of work to do now
especially that Kamara Usman is kind of
on his last leg I think Kamar has maybe
one more
um so I think for Colby
um I don't I don't think you'd entertain
that because it wasn't very competitive
the first time they fought so I don't
see the UFC doing that either so I don't
think so I don't think so
what else you got
at Raza Shani 10 that's
[Music]
r-a-m-z-i-s-h-a-h-e-e-n-10 if Michael
Chandler beats Conor McGregor do you
think it's done for McGregor or can he
find a way to come back from that uh not
done I think McGregor's one of those
guys so never be done his star is so
bright no matter what happens look at
all this stuff that's happened outside
of uh the Octagon he's still a force to
be reckoned with as far as the fans are
concerned he has his loyal fan base and
they're massive they're massive you're
looking at one you know the guy can do
no wrong in my book sometimes he makes
it tough to cheer for him but uh you
know with his history and what he's done
for this game I don't think that fan
base is ever going to go away but
um if you were to get like dominated by
Michael Chandler
it's gonna be tough it's gonna be really
tough for him to to get back in there
um
there are a few guys where if you were
to just get Molly watt by Michael
Chandler would you could jump in there
with uh I could see a Tony Ferguson a
fight like that makes a lot of sense two
guys who are kind of on the back night
of the career something like that the
legendary fight not to mention you know
you didn't uh put can you find his way
back from that
in regards the UFC it'd be really tough
I do think that Tony Fergus Tony
Ferguson fight makes a lot of sense no
matter what uh Win Lose or Draw there
but um can you bounce back from that
outside of the UFC yeah I think uh
there's a lot of big name boxing that
can be
um
available for Conor McGregor outside DFC
you know no matter if his nuts are
hanging down to his ankles I think
people are gonna pay to see him fight a
Jake Paul a KSI listen I get it you guys
are like what I know there's a lane for
it it is what it is but he can take some
of those you know the Nate Diaz Trilogy
fight uh is always just this kind of uh
mythical creature just looming out there
for him whenever him and Nate Diaz
decide to get together I do think that
fight happens but I think it's between
their two promotions or under a
different Banner not the UFC and it's
probably gonna be boxing
at nevin194 what would do more
pay-per-view Buys so here we go what
would do more pay-per-view buys Leon
Edwards versus mosvidal or Leon Edwards
versus Colby Covington
um
uh Edwards and Mos Vidal there's a good
story there right with the was it the
two pieces in a soda
so there's that
shit's kind of sailed right is anybody
really talking about that not really but
we did they could build it up there
um
Edwards maswood all is listen if maswell
it looks great against Gilbert Burns
there would definitely be some hype
there
um
Covington's had a long time off
but he's a fan favorite
um again fan favorite also fan hated so
you know he's a he's a compelling guy
it's two different things right because
Mazel doll's kinda on his like we've
said you know he's kind of on his way
out Covington now I think come the work
now Begins for Covington like not us
one's out of the picture the one guy has
won Achilles heel I think Covington
beats everybody else I think he's the
best want to win on the planet not name
come out Usman especially in his prime
so uh I think
uh more preview bites doesn't mean it's
you know it doesn't mean the the
hardcores or the purest of the sport
um are you gonna make it a bigger
pay-per-view for the purest of the sport
it's Edwards Covington right because
Covington even though he's had a year
off he's definitely a top three guy
Mazda doll even ready to beat Gilbert
Burns can you call him a top three guy
at this point in his career you know
he's a little longer in the tooth
um more pay-per-view buys the question
would be so Edwards is Edwards I think
his Stars bigger than ever but
I think Edwards fans you know especially
across the Palm they're gonna buy the
paper you know what I want so that's a
guarantee so who's more famous in the
grand scheme of things especially with a
common fan is it maswell or Covington
masal is more beloved Covington's more
hated so I think more people know
Covington
it's pretty even it's pretty even even
though Mazda doll has a little bit of a
salty record and Covington's only really
lost to
um Kamara Usman I would say they're
pretty even I don't think I think you're
around 25 000 pay-per-view buys no
matter who it is so it's not you know a
huge drastic uh difference
25 000. I don't think 250 000 difference
I'd say 25 000 like it's that cloud yeah
it's that close yeah it's super close
super close super super close as far as
the division to move on you'd want
Edwards Covington though what else you
got
if Izzy loses is he basically the same
as Robert Whittaker
ah and that's at uh J R young 22. uh if
he's is he based the same as Robert
Whittaker yeah because Izzy's Robert
Whittaker's Achilles heel and Alex
Pierre is uh Izzy's uh Achilles heel so
they're the best guys it just depends on
the the matchups the style the matchups
you know if there's no Izzy Robert
Whittaker's your reigning champ for
quite some time there's no Pierre
um you know then then Izzy's just
dominating so it's just all about
stylistic matchups now is he based same
as Robert Whittaker I don't know
necessarily if that's a bad thing you
know yeah you're not champ but you're
pretty damn good you beat everybody else
not named Izzy adesanya so that's not a
bad place to be in
um
if Izzy Lizzy based the same as Robert
Whittaker
you know Robert working is such a
talented dude because
you know I think Robert Whittaker
would give Alex Pierre a pretty Fierce
Shake as well he's a different animal
um
you know I I guess the question I think
what's gonna be interesting is you know
let's say it's gonna be better for the
UFC if Izzy wins because if Izzy wins
there's a lot more options for him a
little bit even though he's cleaned it
out
um I will say this no matter if Izzy
wins or Alex Pierre wins neither one of
them are going to hold that belt for
very long because uh hamzat's coming and
again it's all about matchups it's not
that this guy's bad or this guy's not
very good or I'm throwing shade on
anybody it's all about stylistic
matchups and stylistically Izzy arasania
and Alex pierra are awful awful
to match up with against hamzat he just
across the board they're going to be a
worse matchup for both those gentlemen
what's interesting is hamzat is a
tougher has a tougher fight against
Robert Whittaker
you know so it's all about at that high
level who has this you know special set
of skills to go against the opponent
that they're facing which just so
happens that the current guy is fighting
for the title would be just in a world
of trouble against hamzat Robert
Whittaker I think it's a when if it went
to DraftKings kind of odds thing Robert
worker would be less of an underdog in
that fight so it's all about stylistic
matchups so
um again I think
it's better for the UFC if Izzy wins and
that forces oxy Pier to jump to light
heavyweight there's better matchups for
him at light heavyweight light
heavyweight could use a boogeyman Ox
beer up there the middleweight could use
some kind of order because we know it's
just a matter of time for Alex Pierre
jumps up there and it's time for Hamza
to kind of Reign Over the middleweight
divisions because Izzy's been that but
this is his 10th title fight you know so
Izzy's been the face of the UFC and the
middleweight division for how long so
sometimes it's good to switch things up
and I think it's just a matter of time
uh again to be very clear I think Hamza
beats Whitaker Izzy and Alex beard so I
think everyone's just keeping that seat
warm to hamzat decides to jump up to
middleweight what else you got
at uh Weirs eight
w-e-y-e-r-s-8 my fight to watch is uh
Pfeiffer uh Merchant so if I forget
submitted quickly by gm3 oh gm3 I like
that does it hurt his stock what would
be next if Pfeiffer gets another
knockout win yeah Pfeiffer is a a bad
mama Jam in the middleweight Division if
you guys aren't familiar with him he was
a two-time uh participant on Dana
White's Contender series first time he
had an elbow injury got hurt uh that was
a number of years ago and then finally
you know you got better better skill set
more mature more experience came back on
Danny White Contender series and uh blew
the roof off the place in a second round
TKO so now the guy's doing the damn
thing he's a legit middleweight
contender in the UFC and uh you know
he's another kid which he's from
Pennsylvania he trains with uh the
Savages out there in Philadelphia and uh
Sean Brady and stuff like that so he's
around uh greatness and really good
competitors so the the sky's the limit
on this kid
um if you were to beat Mercer what
happens for him
you know martial arts no no joke so it's
definitely a big test for the kid but
um he's a big Prospect man I was like
probably rain guy right because martial
kind of is I don't I hate when people
say gatekeeper but it's kind of that
threshold where if you beat him you're
probably right there around 15 14 right
so I would like to see him get the
winner of Kelvin gaslum and uh Curtis
that makes sense and they're on the same
card same division it makes a lot of
sense
what else you got
at Art underscore zero three two one do
we see Logan Paul and UFC especially
after the prime deal absolutely not
um
I think you're gonna see Logan Paul a
lot more right because he's pretty
ingrained with the WWE with the new
accused uh kind of
merger is that where we're gonna say
call it the merger with the WWE and UFC
with uh Vince McMahon and Dana White the
helm
um
you know and Logan Paul's a pretty
um you know he pops up at the WWE pretty
frequently especially the Wrestlemania
stuff like that so he's definitely uh
there's it's gonna be easier for guys to
jump across and cross-pollinate there
and you see Logan Paul more ufcs
um now do I think he's actually gonna
fight in you see I don't think so it
you'll I'll Never Say Never that's what
Dana says right
um but
it's gonna be easier you know because
I'm sure the WWE is going to have some
say in who's going to cross over and
stuff like that so I I would highly
doubt it I don't think Logan Paul uh
wants to do that he says he does
um and it really predicate on the
matchup
you know I I think the whole CM Punk
thing we've tried this right with with
guys that don't really have that
technical background jump in the UFC
it's not a great look for the UFC so I
know Logan did you know the the boxing
but it's just a different animal in the
UFC you know it's the best fighters in
the world it's kind of slap in the face
with those guys but
um it depends how far this WWE
influences the UFC you know that's that
worries me I'll be honest that
definitely worries me it blurs the lines
there so be if this WWE deal didn't
happen I'd be like absolutely not but
because it did makes it a little easier
to transition over the UFC vice versa so
uh it worries me I'll be honest with you
it really worries me with the Integrity
of the UFC and being a professional
sport especially in the top five in in
the world you know so the lines are
getting blurred so that means if the
lines get blurred you'd probably see a
Logan Paul in there at some point
that stuff worries me I'll be honest
what else you got at uh Cami Kazi that's
k-a-m-i-k-o-z-z-z-y what do you think
about Pettis saying him and Anderson
Silva are supposed to fight in the UFC
that's insane
uh what an 85 uh catch weight I guess uh
what are Pettis chances ever getting
back to UFC not good you know especially
now you know he went to pfl and then he
started his own organization and then
he's doing boxing now under mozvidal's
Banner game bread
um I don't see it I don't see it I don't
see why UFC would do it I don't think
there's
much of a uh demand there as in regards
to UFC you know pedis is a Hall of Famer
first battle Hall of Famer so uh next
time you see Paris in the UFC he'll be
on stage getting his gold jacket but as
far as competing UFC those days are over
at what would Rob Baidu would hamzat be
a tougher fight for Izzy or pierra both
of them but
um awful matchup I think both of them
were plus 300 in that fight at least but
I would say it's a tougher fight for
Alex Pierre because
he he's never really fought a guy of
hamzat's level at that caliber of
grappling uh Izzy we know has some
takedown defense we've seen him fight
especially against the the cage he has
really good takedown defense
um is he also took down Pierre right so
um I'd say Izzy
um has more of a upper hand when it
comes out experience the grappling goes
but none of it matters when you're
fighting hamzat he's such a higher level
when it comes to grappling and
submission so
um both of them would be screwed in that
fight but
um it'd be a much tougher fight for homs
out against Izzy than oxpira
and on record uh Hamza did say on ero
Hawaii show that uh appears would be the
easiest fight of his career
while he was at McDonald's
at Jake underscore 9914 does Gilbert
Burns take Maslow down at will no I I
think you guys are doubting Mozilla a
little too much you all must have forgot
Maslow's takedown defense is freaking
good
um you know I know Gilbert Burns had
some success against hamzat uh with the
takedowns even though he got right back
up
um Gilbert burnson trying to knock
Mozilla out Gilbert wins that fight's
gonna be via knockout but Mazda he's
been the game way too long his takedown
defense is very good again especially
against the cage uh I think he's still
athletic and flexible you see guys get a
single leg it's not easy he just trains
with Savages who you know guys like Bo
nickel and the other uh monsters at ATT
uh who have tried to take him down for
years so it's you know don't do that to
miles at all let's not discredit the guy
and go he's just getting it taken down
and choked out nah man you ever seen
that guy [__] fight in the last 15
years it's not that easy so
um I think the pressures on Gilbert
Burns here he's such a big favorite and
muslaw I think added more pressure going
ass might be my last one if I lose so
it's like oh this guy's checked out
Gilbert's gonna starch this guy when
every of that kind of pressure on you
it's a lot it's a lot so uh it's gonna
good fight man I I you know mozilla's no
punk dude it's mazwa doll so
um I do think maslaw has a good showing
but Gilbert uh gets it done
that's Steph come here Cameron 96 Steph
Cameron 96. is there a world where Izzy
beats Pierre within the first two rounds
yeah you look at their last fight listen
there's a reason why Izzy's the favorite
in Vegas right now and it's not because
he's just more popular you know those
guys are experts when it comes to
um setting the lines Izzy had a ton of
success against Oxford in that first
fight a ton of success if there was 30
seconds left in that first round he
finishes them off so to think that Izzy
could do it you know within the first
two rounds is not a stretch there I
think as he gets it done in the first
three rounds I I think if Izzy wins you
know I think he decision if you're in a
better decision is probably the safest
bet but uh if there's a knockout I can
see Izzy uh getting it done in the first
three rounds man so the first two rounds
isn't a far stretch you know you go back
to that first fight is he had a lot of
success he's had a lot of time to study
that tape he's one of the greatest
coaches in the world studying uh Alex
Pierce so I think uh Izzy could get it
done uh via finish in the first two
rounds yeah that's not a far stretch
at Big Dave 6-1-1 from Greenville
Tennessee if Israel wins do you think
they will run it back if he loses will
he put down his gloves
um I think if Izzy wins they absolutely
don't run it back this is the last time
we're going to see these guys fight this
is the fourth fight second the UFC even
though it'd be a three to one uh record
there I just think I don't think
anybody's vying for this thing you know
unless it's like a super controversial
judges score card for Izzy and you think
Alex Pierre won maybe the UFC's like all
right we can't stand up Alex period of
light heavyweight after this [__] so
um I I do think this last time we see
him fight I think the the light
heavyweight is the future of relaxed
Pierre for Izzy
um if he loses doesn't put down his
gloves no because I again Alex Pierre
the middleweight uh division is just a
temporary stop for him his Future's at
light heavyweight and [__] even maybe
heavyweight this guy's gigantic so
um for Izzy he knows you know he knows
that Oxford is not no matter what when
those who draw that Alex Pierre's
Futures up a weight class so I think for
Izzy
um you know he'll get back to work
regardless of what happens you know
there's some matchups for Izzy at light
heavyweight too I think he's more of a
natural middleweight but
um uh he there's certain fights you know
not John blockage but there's certain
fights uh against Strikers like year you
know they're guys like that that he
could uh compete with at light
heavyweight if he wanted to do that too
but middleweight is where he's going to
be at
at T800 Ruben my boy Reuben what's up
man can you comment on the speculation
that the merger between the UFC and WWE
is a strategy for the UFC to retain
their aging fighters on their payroll by
allowing them to use performance
enhancing drugs and potentially having
their fights predetermined how dare you
Reuben speculation you mean you
speculated
uh I love you dude
um
uh so on so he's thinking that the ufcnw
merger was so the UFC can retain their
older Fighters and keep them on the
payroll but allow them to use
performance enhancing drugs and
potentially having their uh fights
predetermined
boy talk about the lines getting blurred
that would absolutely ruin the UFC that
wrecked the UFC and their legacy and uh
it would just become the WWE and they
would completely lose their fan base you
know we had to be the USC has to tread
lightly on this you know by
cross-pollinating here because WWE as
you know it's definitely a tough job
these guys I have some friends who
compete in the WWE uh one was a a world
champion multiple times and she was
telling me like their schedule is
absolutely insane and what they put
their bodies through insane their bodies
stay damaged like uh you know their
their NHL hockey player like they're
constantly on the road jumping on the
tables getting in the face slamming
their bodies like their bodies get
absolutely annihilated that being said
it's not a sport it's just you can't
have a sport predetermined so
um DLC has tread lightly here I don't I
don't think the UFC is going to do it
um I think they know that would ruin
their uh credibility across the board as
being a major sport
um especially for the common fan you
know Common fans like oh is Undertaker
fighting you know is Undertaker fighting
Francis and Ghana this weekend so we
don't want that right
um so if you if if you did this just so
your older guys could say on the you
know on the payroll and take all the
steroids they want and then predetermine
the fight to just be stupid at this
point just why would you just have those
older guys keep their Fame and their fan
base and jump over the WWE where we know
that's what they're doing don't ruin the
UFC and do that so there could be that I
think this is off as far as speculation
goes I think the only reason the UFC and
WWE combined is for money for money
because now the UFC who's with ESPN
WWE's with Fox they combine forces and
when both those TV rights deals are up
they can come to whoever ESPN Fox ABC
Disney whoever and go all right well if
you paid whatever it is however much
millions and millions of dollars just
for the UFC well now we have WWE you
know
stuff as well so think as how much how
much programming they can offer to a
major Network or others can go off on
their own do some subscription base and
make all the [__] money but I think
it's just a money play I think UFC's
gonna know how to tread lightly with
this but I do think there's been a lot
of cross pollinating stuff like that
is that it good questions guys I'm
answered fan question a hot second hope
you enjoyed it we're doing these uh
pretty frequently so keep sending them
in can't thank you guys enough you can
submit your questions at the thick Boy
Instagram whatever questions you have
whatever it is send it there your boy
will answer it thank you guys for
watching like subscribe love you guys uh
enjoy UFC 280 yeah 287. enjoy it this
Saturday check out the fight campaign
live kab ass fight command with me
Cheeto Vera Brian Callan and Sam Tripoli
that's live Saturday 7 P.M only on thick
boy YouTube till next time stay thick
[Music]